[Musique]
ce n'est pas la vallée de la peur mais
elwes tout de même
[Musique]
pour être plus précis c'est l'ouest
d'ermenonville et de la future autoroute
nord à deux journées de marche de la
porte saint denis au coeur de richard
landes
[Musique]
c'est
et quand il se passe quelque chose le
vote n'est jamais bien loin
[Musique]
k
jean richard carr et libyens sur dix là
tout près avec sam et en france et qui
croient enfants le dernier né à quinze
jours c'est à dire que le cirque d'été
et puis de la mer de sable il ya deux
ans et enfin l'aîné le zoo le saut est
un enfant qui m'a donné pas mal de
soucis dans sa jeunesse même il ya même
un journaliste qui a écrit un jour au
sujet d'un film que j'avais tourné et
qui croyait bien n'était pas destiné au
festival métal il a écrit jean richard
et le summum monde qui se permettent de
nourrir des lions avec des navettes
l'amusant et c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours eu envie d'avoir des
animaux j'en ai eu fou c'est un peu plus
et davantage depuis un jour vous pouvez
lui à sion qui menaçait des dramatiques
est ce parce qu'au point de vue de
nourriture j'avais deux solutions
souvent que j'avais ou en acheter dix
fois plus léger au public
j'ai pris la deuxième solution et je ne
regrette rien on regrette seulement une
petite chose c'est qu'à la base de sa y
avait quand même l'amour des animaux
l'amour d'être entouré par des animaux
et puis le nombre
nous on n'a pas de suisse est amour les
l'a rendu difficile c'est évident j'ai
par exemple ici en ce moment si vous
voulez 60 à 65 5 g je fais
obligatoirement preuve de favoritisme
j'aime mieux les gentils
moi
[Applaudissements]
comme la mairie bartek effet
alors
malfait
pour voir une pièce de collection entier
rare c'est un véritable ours kodiak
c'est la plus grande variété de riez
vous même c'est un mètre quatre-vingt il
doit passer quelque chose comme 2 mètre
soixante deux looks à la nature de la
gauche aux poissons et là ils crachent
passe quand les classes de nouveaux
voyous
[Musique]
des accès c'est très moche de m
ces animaux dans des volières qui sont
vraiment faits pour faire partie d'un
paysage avec une course d'euros prêtés
rentiers du déploiement des grues
couronnées demoiselles de numidie et
canards de petites phrases déboires de
même
animal que j'aimerais que vous racontez
ça m'a froissé aniol et les ménageries
qui s'appelait la ménagerie 2 mars à la
corse montée importante dans ma mère
blessée à deux heures
chez martha la torche nord prenait 1,7 à
rochechouart et sur une case y avait des
clips saccadé niel électrique le faut et
à qui il entre avec et alors je rêvais
nous a aidés des rêves de yens alors
qu'il est toujours à mon père mais
j'avais j'avais 8 ans je voulais rentrer
clients' mon père me laisser dire si un
jour quand même s'il a un peu trop venté
une bonne terre devient alors toutes mes
rêves deviennent se sont
dissiper et alors des fiches les rentrer
dans le moule a nié avec une fourche est
un chouette et je leur ai fait un coach
est rendue scop furieux il a fallu
nombreux tués mais mais la battre voilà
ma première rentrée de cash
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que tu as faim bon jus sanfourche
n'y changent rien madame riesch a réussi
également bien en matière de dressage
souvent des gens disent vous avez
beaucoup d'activités sont les jamais de
vacances
erreur je suis toujours en vacances ce
qui n'est pas pareil puisque je fais ce
qui me plaît
donges réaliser un grand rêve celui de
faire du sir parfait en 57 58 sur les
routes de france et non seulement je
n'étais pas déçu par dossier mais je
dois je dire même qu'il est temps de
tout ce que ça m'amenait sa manette une
démangeaison tous les gens le mode marc
dans les cirques pas la route
l'espèce a envie de retenir ce qui est
difficilement conciliable avec mon
métier d'acteur que je conserve quand
même et puis je viens de construire ici
mon dernier né il ya quinze jours
ainsi at-elle été c'est à la fois
merveilleux terrain d'essai pour les
numéros de dressage et des numéros de
cirque en général et qui en plus est
pour moi un merveilleux calme mais vous
avez en piste en ce moment à des zones
de cirque les plus complet que j'aie
connues s'est joué que la veille
d'abord c'est mon ami ensuite c'est mon
directeur du zoo ça a été a les plus
grands numéros aériens sous le nom
dinars
est un des plus grands porteurs au
trapèze volant avant de s'attaquer au
pot il a dressé chez les femmes où
lionne longtemps lyon tille les très
gros numéros d'animaux et il s'attaque
même maintenant ici assez chamakh l'onu
que sont les chimpanzés à kaunas et
recommencer c'est pas bon comme et
l'emploi vous avez en piste sûrement le
plus jeune écuyer français pourtant jean
lucien gruss
enfin il a de qui tenir puisque il est
le fils de du plus grande le maître
écuyer alexis graves ayant retrouvé une
autorité en piste chez un garçon très
sage quand on est sage des chevaux les
le public du public le sent absolument
pas compte de la difficulté du dressage
des chevaux
pour lui le cheval c'est un animal
domestique donc facile à mener aux
jouets et jeux femmes et en dissertation
sur le dressage est très longue mais je
pour vous donner une image trash et
seulement que vous mettez au point trois
numéros de lyon ou de pire quand vous
mettez au point difficilement à numéros
de chevaux en liberté
j'ai créé la mer de sable c'est un lieu
un lieu merveilleux qui avait été fermé
et ouvert au public moyennant un prix
d'entrée car tient bien des
il de faire autour de la merde ça y
était avant tout et vous voyez je suis
resté un j'entends je crois qu'il
voulait rester le plus longtemps
possible créer une espèce de petit
univers à la méliès
il monte mon voyage dans la lune ça
viendra peut-être qui sait j'ai même mes
gardes du corps sont pas sots catégories
sont des des vrais cow-boys peux pas
vous le garantir authentique du texas
mais ils en ont l'air quand même
et là on circule on a l'impression de
circuler d'inde dans les parties du
monde partie du monde ans
à tour du monde en
en dix minutes
ça chameau aligner leur qui s'appelle
champignol heureusement
et puis
plus loin à la ballade i
[Musique]
te dire que tu cela attire beaucoup de
monde et sans doute superflu dimanche
entre total de vingt mille personnes
autrement dit ermenonville c'est ma
fille de 5 ans la du temps
harvey mille personnes en semaine et
entre la mer de sable et l'eau
35000 habitants ce dimanche la pousse
comme un champignon
[Musique]
m
nous arrivons dans une zone difficile et
dangereuse même un endroit où ma tête
est mise à prix
wycoff garde
je décroche de rechange partie enfin au
moins cinq fois dans l'après midi
[Musique]
ah ah
protéger ajouté
we came incident
[Musique]
la face
on a plus
autoritaire
[Musique]